resuelve para x 5 x 7 mayor que 3 x + 1
muy bien entonces lo que nos piden en
resolver esta desigualdad para el
conjunto de valores x que los satisface
en verdad así que lo que tenemos que
hacer es simplificar el lado derecho y
eso nos va a llevar a una desigualdad
muy conocida en el sentido de que ya
hemos hecho muchos muchos muchos
ejercicios de este estilo entonces vamos
a intentar despejar la x de un lado así
que vamos a empezar simplificando el
lado derecho y esto es 5 x más 7 mayor
que y lo que hacemos es distribuir este
producto verdad sería 3 x x 3 x y 3 x 1
es más 3 muy bien entonces para pasar
las x todas de un lado qué tal si
restamos de ambos lados 3 x podemos
restar 3 x de ambos lados y eso por
supuesto no cambia el signo de mi
desigualdad porque sólo estamos restando
entonces del lado izquierdo que nos
queda nos queda 5 x menos 3 x que son 2
x
se queda igual y la desigualdad no
cambia solo restamos y esto se cancela
en verdad ese era el punto central de
restar 3x entonces si se cancelan solo
me queda un 3 muy bien entonces para
seguir despejando nuestra equis qué tal
si ahora restamos 7 de ambos lados para
quitar este estorbo de aquí entonces qué
es lo que me queda 2 x más bueno este 2x
se queda aquí el si los 7 se cancelan y
del lado derecho me quedan 3 menos 7 son
menos 4 ahora la desigualdad sigue
siendo la misma porque no dividimos ni
multiplicamos por un número negativo
ahora bien ya para despejar la x
necesitamos dividir ambos lados entre 2
y como 2 es un número positivo y esta
desigualdad sigue siendo la misma
entonces del lado izquierdo ya me queda
x que es mayor que menos 4 entre 2 que
eso es
2 muy bien vamos a ver cómo se vería
esto en la recta numérica
por ejemplo si tenemos aquí nuestra
recta numérica que digamos que aquí anda
el menos tres menos dos
el 0 el 1 el 2 y el 3 y con eso basta
entonces nos dice que x toma todos los
valores más grandes que menos 2 entonces
empezamos en menos 2 pero no lo
incluimos por lo tanto ponemos una
bolita abierta verdad y no seguimos
hacia la derecha que son todos los
valores reales que son más grandes que
nuestro menos 2 muy bien entonces vamos
a intentar algo que funcione y algo que
no para que más o menos te convenzas de
ello por ejemplo algo que sí funcione es
el cero entonces vamos a ver si eso
funciona 5 vamos a sustituirlo aquí 5
por 0 más 7 será mayor que 3 por 0 3
pues ojalá si verdad entonces cinco por
cero es cero y entonces acá me queda 7
más grande que 3 por 0 es 0 más 3 y sí
sí es cierto que 7 es más grande que 3
verdad eso lo sabemos desde la primaria
muy bien ahora vamos a tomarnos 1
que no está en este conjunto por ejemplo
el menos 3 muy bien vamos a sustituir
con menos 3 y tenemos 5 x menos 37 es
mayor que 3 x menos tres más 3 vamos a
ver si es cierto aquí que tenemos 5 x
menos 3 es menos 15 más 7 es menos 8 y
esto será mayor que 3 x menos 3 que es
menos 9 + 3 es menos 6 y esto por
supuesto que no es cierto menos 8 es
mucho más negativo que menos 6 por lo
tanto es más chico entonces esto no es
cierto así que es bueno que menos 3 no
funcionará porque porque menos 3 no está
en nuestro conjunto solución intentamos
con algo que sí estaba en nuestro
conjunto solución y funcionó intentamos
algo que no estaba y no funcionó así que
eso nos hace sentir bastante bastante
bien